mr speaker huge efforts have been made
over the last two years
and we would not be where we are today
without the heroism of our nhs and key
workers
those who pioneered and rolled out the
vaccines
and the sacrifices
that people made every day
to follow the rules and protect our
public health
we must honor the collective sacrifices
of the british people and do everything
possible to prevent a return to the loss
and lockdowns we've seen over the last
two years
the prime minister promised to present a
plan for living with covid
but all we've got today is yet more
chaos and disarray
not enough to prepare us for the new
variants which may yet develop
an approach which seems to think that
living with covid means simply ignoring
it this morning he couldn't even
persuade its own health secretary to
agree the plan so what confidence can
the public have that this is the right
approach
mr speaker let me be clear the labour
party does not want to see restrictions
in place for a moment longer than
necessary
but mr speaker we have to take the
public with us
and that requires clarity
order if you can't show the respect that
i expect with the prime minister to be
heard inside expect lead with opposition
if you don't wish to be in here there's
plenty of room outside this chamber i
suggest you start using it and i'll be
helping you on your way so let's have
silence
mr speaker we have to take the public
with us
and that requires clarity about why
decisions are being made
so will the prime minister publish the
scientific evidence behind his decision
to remove the legal requirement to
self-isolate including the impact on the
clinically extremely vulnerable
for whom lockdown has never ended
having come this far
i know the british people will continue
to act responsibly and they will do the
right thing
testing and then isolating if positive
what i can't understand is why the prime
minister is taking away the tools that
will help them to do that
free tests can't continue forever but if
you're 2-1 up with if you're
if you're 2-1 up with 10 minutes to go
you don't sub off one of your best
defenders
[Music]
the prime minister
the prime minister is also removing
self-isolation support payments that
allow many people to isolate and
weakening sick pay
these are decisions which will hit the
lowest paid and the most insecure
workers the hardest
including care workers who got us
through the toughest parts of the
pandemic
it's all very well advising workers to
self-isolate
but that won't work unless all workers
have security of knowing that they can
afford to do so
the prime minister mentioned
surveillance and the ons infection
survey
this is crucial to ensuring that we can
ramp up testing and vaccination if the
virus returns
so can the prime minister confirm that
he has put the funding in place to
ensure that the ons infection survey
will not see reduced capacity
and that he will be able to track the
virus with the same degree of detail as
it can today
we can't turn off british britain's
radar
before the war is won
ignorance's bliss is not a responsible
approach to a deadly virus
it actually risks undoing all the
hard-won progress the british people
have achieved over the last two years
mr speaker the labour party has
published a comprehensive plan for
living well with covid
our plan would see us learn the lessons
of the past two years and prepared for
new variants
his approach will leave us vulnerable
where's the plan to secure the uk supply
of testing why are skilled schools still
not properly ventilated
as a nation there is no doubt we need to
move on from covid
people need to know their liberties are
returning and returning for good
but this is a half-baked announcement
from a government paralyzed by chaos and
incompetence it is not a plan to live
well with kobe